friendly conversation this is a friendly
conversation this is an impressive
oh yeah it is a podcast it's like a
podcast is a friendly conversation I'm
recording it it's a it'll be put out
later so I know what first that's smart
you never think about that well I don't
and I end up saying bad things sometimes
yeah and plus most of the things I'm
doing don't know I'm on all the
spectrums I mean I guess I mean I like
to think I carry myself in a certain way
I'm just skinny really it's unseemly
yeah well I mean camera adds 10 pounds
so yeah as if I eight out of 10 pounds
to the right places but do you enjoy
doing comedy in these new normal and
this new normal
what did you do I did a live show from
I've been election my balcony I've got a
balcony in my apartment that overlooks a
courtyard yeah maybe hundred people or
50 people so we let everyone in the
building come into the courtyard and
maybe there maybe 15 people so they were
pretty spread out and then the neighbors
came out from their windows and stuff so
it was Elliott Thompson and Michael
Terry and mean it was really just an
experiment you livestreams it that was
really fun because people watched it and
people in the real world toward the
beginning of the quarantine that's
awesome all those juicy counting jokes
all those juicy quarantine can I watch
this I mean I think maybe like you're
being critical cuz you're like an artist
and you're like it wasn't my best
performance but I think
but Michel Michel Therrien did great
although we lost all of his footage that
didn't that didn't get streams and
Elliot Thompson just murder he was so
fantastic
there was great comics yeah they're so
unique and he's from Brooklyn Elliot
Thompson yeah yes so the local Flair all
these different states I don't want my
material it's a somewhat it's not a very
unique experience and so you know I'm
thinking about possibly it's a long
story but maybe going to Tennessee I
mean I don't know if it'll work out and
maybe it'll be for a couple of months
but at least it'll be an adventure and
I'll try something and some material
some life experience to write about you
yeah so doing it on purpose
you're being purposeful with your life
New York is coming back in the way
that's going to allow for comedy within
a year or so I just can't imagine all
right I mean it's gonna be the last
thing because people don't want to
gather in large groups for fun they it's
like not necessarily buying the drinks
at these places charge for you to
perform there or you know to have a show
some of the stage just simply might not
even be open and even they may have gone
out of business some of the bars and the
places that we did some of these shows I
mean the big places like Gotham will
probably stay open it I guess but my
thought was Tennessee might have larger
spaces where a club could stay open with
50% capacity and still pay their rent I
just don't think that's possible in New
York City so I'm just trying to make I
don't want to not do comedy for a year I
want to I don't want to wait so I'm
gonna try to go someplace where I can
create something and then if that
doesn't work I'm trying to maybe could
possibly try to maneuver myself into
Berlin
because I think I was supposed to do
nine shows there already and now those
got cancelled because of the travel ban
and so I already have some connections
there and I can you can get by in
English there's a pretty robust comedy
community there in English so yeah
that's kind of my plan right now
that's awesome I mean it's good to nuts
like be hunkered down in one place and
to be versatile and I like I need to
kind of rent it before I can really make
these moves so yeah I'm trying to rent
it out but like I can't I can't give a
proper lease because that's just not a
possibility right now because I'm only
only want someone to kind of take it for
three months at first just to see what
happens yeah are they awesome I mean you
know yeah you could just put it on
Craigslist and as soon as you get a
nibble you could be like all right I'm
out Earl I guess someone bites yeah yeah
there's a social contract but I don't
know like sometimes friends are even
worse than strangers yeah it's just the
very beginning of a conversation a nice
conversation I told them about my
interest they said there might be an
opportunity down there but for now
they're gonna give me an assignment I
think to do up here and I'm gonna do
that with Steve so you know we'll have
something to work on together so you're
still going comedy money did you wear a
mask and white gloves and yeah do you
know someone had it like in the comedy
community you know yeah I don't know
these people
what about like me show Shakur faith
haven't Mia faith Hammond she's the
daughter of Darrell Hammond I think just
to really well he was on SNL I just
think that's cool I mean she's so she
had it seems like she's been doing
comedy from birth
I understand I saw that she to the Titan
five in utero which was fantastic
I'm glad she didn't choke on the birth
canal or the umbilical cord that's why
she's so good with a mic cord right now
she clings on to for life be disturbing
are you what are you talking about
you have boyish is boyish is is that
where you go to Tennessee well they are
covered 19 you're clean southern boy
perverted with your city ways
[Music]
yeah but uh it's an interesting time
it's just like I've been talking to
Hosea boy and that's pretty much it I
just mostly keep to myself
he's uh it's like a drunk Mexican guy he
looks like a like a [ __ ] Don Juan I
guess he's like that medicine man he's
like a mystical Mexican Raven God yeah
he's great who also I've been talking to
Oh Ryan D you know Ryan D what'd you say
hello can you hear me
can you hear me can you hear me
hey all right so what did I say oh yes
I've had it anyways Ryan D yeah he's
holed up in a studio in Park Slope er
yeah he's building like a statue of like
a poop emoji yeah I yeah you know I mean
I think comedy brings interesting people
and interesting people now to do
interesting things no matter what's
going on sorry I think this is a good
spot hopefully I found a good spot but I
mean what do you think about you know
anything and in the world do you want to
comment on you can say that the lockdown
protesters are a bunch of who has I mean
they have a point it's just it's just a
matter of perspective it's just like I
don't know I think that it's great that
we could all do this together and we're
in quarantine and I think I think it's
good to take a break from the economy
even though it's a little traumatic
right now but I think overall I think
that it could be a good thing but I
don't know I I don't know how pandemics
work yeah yeah oh you always remember
your first pandemic
so I started in Florida when it really
all went down and then Miami I was just
like rolling around and then I had to
like buy a bunch of ramen and like tuna
canned tuna and it's not been a great
greatest cuisine wise but I was in the
Everglades I met a friend in the Osceola
woods and North Florida and I got out of
there like three weeks ago four weeks
ago I'm in Seattle now wait living
outside or I live with my parents but I
have my car outside so I can come here
for some privacy it's like my own little
room no I just have a nice parking spot
that's all I really need and then I have
solar panels solar panels so so it's and
then I'm live been living here for like
two and a half three weeks almost three
weeks now and this quarantines taking a
lot longer than I thought it would so
hopefully my parents are just sick of me
sucks man who could have called this
like I thought comedy was good like we'd
always have comedy anyway so I'm about
to wrap up the podcast I don't know it's
it's a really good spot it's like two
stops three stops off the El from
Manhattan right cuz there's the first
one and then there's the one that
connects angiogram so off the gram on
the L and it's really it's like five
minutes walking if it's a good apartment
and it's nice and it's you have to be
rich you can't just be like a broke
comedian
next thing I'm not a real comedian and
no I'm saying that real comedians are
poor and you're privileged and comforted
with your pillow of rich miss well
that's part of the fun yeah Oh WN with
an Asian guy yeah my dirty ass retainer
I left it at your house your beautiful
house this leave it closed it's not like
the pulp fiction yeah it's nasty yellow
beautiful I'm glad they taken that was
already beautiful like they already
reconstructed the [ __ ] out of it that's
awesome one day and listen to your
stories about Seattle and what life is
like it's not easy
Oh pulling him right back and we'll talk
about the retainer is that cool sure
okay Oh